from teen heartthrobs to grumpy old men
and the Hollywood royalty in between
celebrities worldwide have been chiming
in on Israel's military offensive in
Gaza and it's proven to be a political
and tweetable issue dividing them maybe
you don't care that Selena Gomez is
praying for Gaza and that blossom I mean
mine they all like from the Big Bang
Theory really supports the Israeli army
but when it comes to public opinion the
spotlight these stars cast on issues
have potentially influenced a lot of
people but with great power comes great
controversy rihanna kicked off the
latest round with a tweet and quick
delete of hashtag free Palestine one
direction Zayn Malik posted the same
hashtag to his 13 million followers and
left it up that earned him 300 thousand
retweets and also a lot of death threats
people are angry like Joan Rivers who in
her support for Israel showed no
sympathy when asked about Gaza as many
dead civilians I don't care they started
that's not what Spanish actors Javier
Bardem and Penelope Cruz felt when they
signed an open letter denouncing
Israel's offensive as well genocide the
letter also urged Israel to lift its LOC
aid of Gaza and blasted Israel's
occupation of Palestinian land but of
course not everyone agreed with that
letter the backlash and accusations of
anti-semitism that followed including a
letter from Jon Voight
aka Angelina Jolie's dad were so fierce
that both Bardem and Cruz issued
statements to clarify their great
respect for Israelis and their hope for
peace others have set their sights on
Hamas Bill Maher tweeted dealing with
Hamas is like dealing with a crazy woman
who's trying to kill you you can only
hold her wrist for so long before you
have to slap her really bill really
Howard Stern took a remarkably less
sexist tone she's tired of bullshit if
you're anti-israel in your anti America
but singer John Legend actually faulted
America venting that he is so sick
watching our Secretary of State have to
grovel so hard to tell Israel how much
he loves them while the Israeli cabinet
and Russell Brand and Fox's Sean Hannity
battled in back-and-forth videos they've
shown too much restraint shown too much
restraint
what they're doing now is alright
Israel's bombing of hospitals led to
global outrage but Mark Ruffalo tweeted
such bombing should be off-limits the
backlash was so harsh he had to defend
himself empathizing with Gaza does not
make the anti-semitic nor Pro Hamas or
anti-israel it makes me human it's still
a dicey topic but things have come a
long way since in 1978 smear campaign
against actress Vanessa Redgrave who
supported the Palestinian cause a recent
Pew poll shows young Americans blame
Israel more than Hamas for the violence
unlike the rest of the country but will
this always be a taboo subject to touch
what do you think nustar's opinions
matter to you or make you want to learn
more
[Music]